un regain de tension entre les
etats-unis et la chine après la
publication des images satellites
capturés en chine par une société
américaine oui selon cette entreprise et
les photos montreraient des
reproductions de navires américains qui
servirait de cible lors d'entraînements
militaires de l'armée chinoise voyez les
précisions de notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet et la réaction
de donald trump
ce sont des clichés qui ont été publiés
par une entreprise américaine qui
s'appelle max art technology qui dévoile
donc des photos satellites prises dans
une région désertique de l'ouest de la
chine ces images ont ensuite été
utilisées par l'institut navale des
états unis pour affirmer que pékin
reproduit des maquettes de navires
américains dans le cadre d'entraînements
militaires alors c'est vrai que sur ces
images on voit des silhouettes qui
s'apparente par exemple à un destroyer
ou un porte avions de l'us navy des
images qui ont été analysés par
l'institut navale des états unis appuyé
dans cette tâche par une société de
renseignement américaine et pour eux
cela ne fait aucun doute ces maquettes
ont été fabriquées pour reproduire le
plus fidèlement possible des navires de
guerre américains il affirme aussi que
ce site en chine a été utilisé dans le
passé pour des exercices balistiques et
pour eux donc ses maquettes s'inscrivent
elles aussi dans le cadre
d'entraînements militaires de l'armée
chinoise invité à réagir le porte-parole
de la diplomatie chinoise a dit qu'il
n'était pas au courant de la situation
mais évidemment ces affirmations
suffisent à relancer des tensions entre
pékin et washington il y à des passes
d'armes très régulièrement entre les
deux diplomaties encore tout récemment
pékin dénoncé par exemple est justement
les manoeuvres maritimes de navires
américains et canadiens dans le détroit
de taiwan alors malgré ces tensions
grandissantes entre les deux puissances
et bien pour l'ancien président donald
trump joe biden fait preuve de faiblesse
face à la chine c'est ce qu'il a déclaré
sur l'antenne de fox news où elle a été
invitée à réagir plus précisément sur le
fait que joe biden et eu un entretien
téléphonique avec son homologue chinois
le président petit jean ping pour parler
de la compétition entre les deux pays
voici ce qu'en dit donald trump et je ne
pense pas que ce soit la bonne façon de
s'adresser à la chine ça fait tellement
faible ça a montré notre faiblesse la
chine est respectée ce pays quand
j'étais président la chine ne respecte
plus notre pays c'est triste une
tonalité qu'on retrouve chez beaucoup de
républicains mais finalement cette
attitude offensive à l'égard de pékin
n'est pas l'apanage du parti républicain
il ya beaucoup de voix qui s'élèvent aux
états unis pour faire part de leur
inquiétude sur les activités chinoises
inquiétudes sur l'éventualité d'un
conflit armé entre les deux pays on sait
que par exemple le dossier taïwanais a
cristallisé les tensions depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois voyez par
exemple ce qu'on peut lire dans les
colonnes du journal the atlantic qui
pour le coup ne peut pas être accusé
d'une quelconque proximité avec l'ancien
président donald trump le président joe
biden a dit que les états unis ne
cherchent pas une nouvelle guerre froide
mais c'est une mauvaise façon de
regarder les relations etats unis chine
une guerre froide avec pékin est déjà en
cours la bonne question en réalité est
de savoir si les états unis peuvent
empêcher la chine d'initier une guerre
chaude tous ces éléments illustrent une
escalade des tensions entre pékin et
washington depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois il ya beaucoup de sujets de
discorde entre les deux pays et ce n'est
évidemment par hasard si washington a
décidé à de faire de la chine sa
priorité sur la scène internationale une
priorité matérialisée notamment par la
création le mois dernier d'une unité au
sein de la cia une unité 100% dédié aux
activités chinoises